- I'm a big fan of your work from Glee.
As a part of the LGBTQ community,
I grew up in a very strict,
religious household,
maybe something similar
that you can relate to,
and I wanted to ask, as someone
who never really had a coming out moment,
what is your advice to the youth of today,
in America and the world,
that you could give them
as someone who may be struggling
with their sexuality or their identity?
- Well, you said the religious household,
so, you know, to give blanket advice
to everybody is really hard to do
because, in some cases, it
might ruin life for the child.
So, it's really one of
those things that there's,
Dan Savage has a program
called It Gets Better
and I would suggest to anybody
who's struggling with their sexuality,
who's in a religious family
or lives in a place where
they wouldn't be accepted
or if they think they might
even put themselves in danger,
I would go to Dan Savage's It Gets Better.
I mean, President Obama is on it.
It's everybody telling their stories
about what it was like to come out
and like, successful people,
and some of them are even straight
who are saying, "Hang in there."
You'll know when the moment is right
and it's really hard
for me to tell somebody
what that moment would be.
You really have to figure
that out for yourself,
but know it gets better, and it does.
(audience applauds)